this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host christy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book business
boutique is my co-host today
as we take your questions at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the call is free and some say the advice
is worth exactly what you pay for it
triple eight eight two five five two two
five christy is also in olympia
washington and is our first caller of
the hour hi christy how are you
i'm good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
okay um i'm a little nervous um so bear
with me um i've been dying i think i've
been dying to
have a reason to call you and i finally
do
um
we have a house in california that we're
currently renting out
my husband's in the military we bought
the house
before he joined
um
so we are renting it out currently we're
not making any money on it um we
considered raising the rent just to make
ends meet
but my question is
we're due to we're on track to move
again in six months to new mexico
um
ultimately we would love to be back in
california
back into our hometown
should we sell it yes
and i knew that was going to be your
answer but i didn't know what you
thought with the current market what you
thought it would be and um let's try
let's try reverse engineering it okay
you're in the military and you're moving
from city to city and you're not going
to be in california for at least five
more years
correct
and you don't own a house there let's
pretend you don't own a house there
and you woke up one more and thought you
know what i'm going to go over in this
little town in california and buy a
rental house
that i don't make any money on
you would never do that
right
and yet you have
so let's undo it sell it
and and okay so now we
currently
might be um profiting like a hundred
thousand
would we
should we
just put that into something and let it
sit there so when we do come back to
california we got a big chunk of change
to put down on a house or should we buy
something in new mexico that make a
great house fund do you have any diving
debt though
no no debt we have um 30 000 in the
savings wonderful okay yeah i would just
take whatever profits you have of course
pay your taxes on it
and set it aside in a um future real
estate mutual fund put in a mutual fund
and just in your in your mind you could
kind of mark that file that's my house
fund for the future and you can keep
adding to it by the way if you want to
that wouldn't hurt anything
and by the way there's not a law that
says that you're necessarily going to
end up back in california when you're
done
five years ago you never dreamed you'd
be where you are right now
that's true we do want to be back in our
hometown with family that would be our
goal and that's and that's why we have a
smaller mortgage right now with that
house
i would just be afraid of coming back to
california and and then getting into a
bigger mortgage than before just because
of the prices well the problem is you're
going to lose money between now and then
and you're going to wish you had just
not had to fool with this whole thing
you're better off not long-distance
landlording you're better off not
fooling with this it doesn't make sense
and so um and we're not i mean i know
it's your goal to be back there but no
one knows i mean five years is a long
time a lot of stuff happens in five
years yeah things may change dave you
use this example a lot so speak to the
principal at play there because
regardless of the circumstances
christie's question was about the house
but i hear you say that a lot okay let's
reverse engineer it
if this was not true whatever the
circumstances are would you go do it
would you go buy it would you create it
the answer is always no right that the
question answers no no no necessarily i
mean you know uh if i didn't own a ski
boat
i'd be buying one this week because i'm
going to the lake this weekend
right but i'm saying something that
someone's trying to get out of i guess
i mean the point is she do i keep it or
do i sell it yes and you can ask that
about anything an investment
you can ask it about
a ski boat you can ask it about um
whatever but if you look at something
and you say
if i didn't already own that i wouldn't
go buy it
for the very reasons that you wouldn't
go buy it you're not using it you don't
like it it's about investment it's
whatever it's the same reasons you
wouldn't keep it
that was what i was going to ask so
whenever you ask the question if this
weren't true would you go do it are
there ever circumstances where that
doesn't apply so you're saying it's like
if the answer is yes i would go do this
today anyway
then then you'd keep then you know okay
you keep it okay so for instance let's
say um
the the first place this always comes up
is within a pure investment like let's
say let's say you um
bought stock in
i'll just make up a company home depot
okay about stock at home depot and let's
say you bought it at 75 dollars a share
and it went down
to 50 a share
and you say gosh
i'm gonna wait on it to come back up i
go well would you buy
stock at 50 a share yeah because i've
got real reason to think it's going to
come up right then you would sit and
wait to come up and you say oh no i
wouldn't buy the 50 a share i wish i
hadn't bought it at 75 dollars a share
because i think it's going to go down
then why then why are you falsely
waiting on it to come back up to be your
measure of when you sell it you need to
say you don't analyze it based on the
past you analyze it based on the future
yeah okay you're forward-looking with
your decisions and going okay if i
wouldn't do that again now
then i don't keep doing it just because
of the past yeah and that's an
investment is called a sunk cost
analysis what you've put into it your
cost is irrelevant as to whether you
keep it
virtually irrelevant i mean you may have
some tax implications but it's virtually
irrelevant the the investment analysis
should be and for that matter the
position of a boat should be the future
of that not my family's always had a
boat i've always had a boat this boat's
not been in the water for 10 years it
sits in my garage but but because of the
past i'm going to continue to keep this
thing in the garage yeah okay well
that's dumb yeah but if you're going to
use it this weekend and you've always
used it in the summer then you would go
get a boat or you would keep your boat
in that case so you're looking forward
with all of your decision-making
analysis
uh not the past the weight of the
emotions the weight of the cost of the
item
not that and so you know if you would go
and buy a small house in a small town in
california because you're afraid real
estate prices are going to go up and if
you didn't own it now and you would go
do that now i wouldn't suggest that but
if you would do it right then maybe you
would keep it different and that's where
we see it the most every time i host
with you it's always around real estate
i had a house i'm holding the house now
i'm renting out the house and it's
another state and the house is almost
always inherited into that situation
meaning
no one set out in those situations to be
a landlord right right it's a landlord
by default is where most of those
questions come from yes i became a
landlord by default i got married we
moved into her house
but we kept mile house as a rental
that's landlord by default we're in the
military we moved we bought a house
everywhere we've been and every time we
move off we turn it into a rental
property that's not i decided that's
going to be my rental
investment strategy it's landlord by
default yeah and it's not wise it almost
never leads you to a good real estate
purchase yeah or keeping the right piece
of real estate as an investment uh i i
own
one piece of property that i formerly
lived in
right now and it's a great rental and i
would buy it again as a rental so i i
passed the acid yeah but but you know
there but but the house i currently live
in would not be a great rental yeah it's
too stinking ridiculous you know so not
a good idea so it's going to be sold
yeah no that's the deal this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure talk just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is the
co-host of the ramsey show today
the christy wright show is where you can
hear her
on her podcast it's where faith meets
personal development
so you can have a bigger faith and a
better life get the encouragement that
you want the tough love truth you need
to connect with god take control
and enjoy your life
new episodes every tuesday on youtube
and anywhere you listen to
podcasts
the christy wright show be sure and
check it out phone number here is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best possible deal
today's question comes from nema in
maryland my husband and i have no debt
we have a significant savings account
considering our income and my husband is
super responsible with the budget the
problem is that i can't stand to budget
i hate the accountability the time it
takes and how confusing it is
besides for just sucking it up and
telling myself to be a big girl what can
i do
to shift my mindset
and my actions
this is interesting to me because i'm
curious
i feel like there's more there of why
don't you like it because it really
shouldn't be that confusing especially
if you have no debt and you are using
something simple like every dollar where
it's actually fun to drag and drop your
expenses and their categories and um you
know i don't know i don't know if you
don't if you don't know why something
matters you don't want to do it but if
you could see the payoff of how you
actually control your money versus it
controlling you then the means to the
end becomes worth it i don't know what
do you think dave what
what else is she saying in that question
um
but i'm not sure uh that there's
obviously a lot of possibilities
number one um
yeah you need to know why you're doing
it uh
because otherwise
it's not confusing it's really not that
hard and it doesn't take that much time
once you start doing it so it really
does come down to the accountability
and uh
you know so
if you're self-admitting i'm a princess
and i don't want to be told no even by
my own self for my own good
then you might as well eat a box of
donuts at every meal
and be 800 pounds
i mean if you have no self-control
whatsoever yeah and no accountability to
for your own benefit yeah i mean you
know it's just it's just misbehavior
it's just immaturity at that point but i
don't think that's really what it is
here um
i'm kind of thinking that that you know
i'm a spender and i learned to love the
budget because it gives me permission
to spend that's what i'm saying i wonder
if what she's saying without saying it
is her and her husband don't see the
budget the same so like for her she
doesn't feel the freedom to put in the
budget what she wants to spend money and
feels that we have money to spend on i
don't think she's got a voice in this
yeah but she hasn't bothered to take it
either she's copping out yeah yeah you
know i just need to be a big girl
there's a little whining going on yeah
so uh you know yeah you do need to be a
big girl and you need to speak up and
say okay we've got plenty of room in
this budget we make plenty of money we
don't have any debt and we're going to
put some joy on the paper here you set
the budget you can make it look like
whatever you want it to her money yeah
it's your money but you're not in
congress you can't just spend not
infinite you just can't keep going and
going and going and going and going that
doesn't work
so yeah you do have to have some
boundaries but they that but they're
your boundaries you get to set them so a
i think she's probably not speaking into
it doesn't feel like she's got control b
probably nerd husband's got the budget
too tight yes to where there's no joy in
this thing
um and then see yeah you do have to be a
big girl and suck it up yeah uh there's
part of that in there too no whining
allowed but it might be that you just
need to take control of this it is a
spending plan yeah
it's how you're going to spend your
money yeah so it's not saying you know
dave ramsey doesn't want me to ever have
fun again oh shut up
the whole point of living like no one
else is later you can live and give like
no one else the whole point of paying a
price to win is and by the way it's your
choice dave ramsey's not coming to your
house right and straighten you out right
every night when you misbehave i mean
this is a matter of are you going to be
a grown up and are you going to control
your destiny that's all it is it's not
me telling you and i and i don't think
that you need to live on beans and rice
the rest of your life and i don't hate
poor people i have been both
um and it's easier when you have a
little money so i'm trying to teach you
how to have a little money it's that
simple
so
you know the whining lefties are just
beyond belief but they're there
and so she's not that her thing is she
just isn't speaking into this and she
doesn't feel power yeah you know feel
like she's gaining power over her life
and this thing
is being used by her husband to control
her yeah yeah and she points out we have
no debt we have significant savings
considering our income and my husband is
super responsible for the budgets
there's all the backstory why can't you
i can't stand to budget you need to
answer the question why can't you stand
the budget and she says i don't like
it's confusing it takes time that's bull
it's absolutely bull yeah she's not
represented in the budget you're not
represented you don't have any say you
don't feel like you have any say maybe
he's not being hardcore but you're just
anticipating that he is right maybe
that's the way you were raised i don't
know what's going on here but but
there's there's something about you need
a voice in this you need to set it
you've got some room you need to put
some fun some joy on the paper enjoy
your money
some of it but then yes you need to have
guardrails we all you never make enough
money to not have guardrails yeah i mean
i make a lot of money and i have
guardrails yeah you know i have
boundaries you have a plan they're
different boundaries than when i was
broke yeah but there's still boundaries
there's still guardrails you know you
got different different situations so
all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five thank
you for joining us america we're glad
you're here christy wright is our
co-host if you've been paying attention
the real estate market this year you've
noticed that competition out there is
really high it's a cray-cray real estate
market in part because inventory has
been hitting all-time lows it is truly a
seller's world
now when inventory is low it simply
means there's more buyers buying than
sellers selling which turns the pressure
up the price is up the bidding wars
start this is not amateur hour you don't
want to be playing out there without a
pro in your corner
you're going to get hammered
to win in this market you need a pro by
your side if you're buying or selling
a monkey can sell a house but not
necessarily for the right price
and lots of monkeys wouldn't got their
real estate licenses this year
a bunch of them they've sold two houses
in their entire life and you're going to
put your largest asset up for sale with
them dumb idea now you need a pro in
your corner and you can instantly
connect with one of our endorsed local
providers high octane high protein real
estate agents
ramsey solutions dot com agent find a
ramsey trusted
agent near you ramsey solutions dot com
slash
agent open phones triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in and
we will talk linda is here in boise
idaho hi linda how are you
hi dave and christy thank you for taking
my call sure um this call is probably
more for christy
my son
played in the minor leagues for the cubs
and he's also been a high school
and a college pitching coach
but that that's in the past and he would
like to start his own pitching
consultant business
um he works full-time this would be on
the side and i would be the manager
so
what do you do to get started
i have i have so many follow-up
questions linda is this something you
want to do
i know it's his idea i know he's good at
it i know all that but let's talk about
you for a second is this something you
want to do
yes i'm retired
it'll give me
something to focus on i
i'm all in
okay
what does he
uh what's his vision for this business
he works full-time this is a side gig is
it just for fun is it to make some extra
cash does he want to grow it to be the
full-time thing
uh probably just for fun when he goes on
the baseball field
he sees young children you know third
fourth fifth grade uh having poor
fishing mechanics which could affect
their future
one in high school linda hang on the
hang on through the break we're gonna
answer your question when you get back
so we can dig into this yeah we want to
dig into a little bit more and give you
a good solid answer we'll be right back
with you this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the ramsey show kristy wright
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five we're talking with linda in
boise idaho her son is wanting to start
a side gig doing pitching coaching he
has been a professional ball player and
he's asking his mom linda to run the
coaching business
i guess while he does the coaching and
christie was in the process of helping
her with that yeah so linda let's do a
quick recap when we left and went to
break i was asking what's the vision for
this business so is this going to stay
aside business does you want to grow it
to full time let's kind of pick up there
i think probably for now it would be a
side business
um he just got his masters in social
work so he'll be working
professionally with children on that
side so this i would just be
keeping into the baseball okay
well i'll tell you what jumps out to me
first there's there's a lot you want to
uh plan for especially because you would
be running something that is your son is
actually fulfilling the
uh the business side of it of the
coaching consulting pitching you know
that type of thing here's what i would
get really clear on linda really clear
what is he doing
and what are you doing let's get real
clear on that what what does he want you
to do for the business is it the books
is it the marketing is it the day-to-day
admin work um
who's wearing which hats so who's
wearing the marketing hat who's wearing
the accounting hat that type of thing
obviously he would be doing the uh
actual coaching but when you say running
the business that includes a lot of
things and i'm curious if there's
aspects of that he wants to do or
expects to do
and then what he wants and expects you
to do just just get on the same page i
would actually write it out i would sit
down and get really clear you know what
does this look like to you let's define
it let's let's write it out
and then also what are um
goals vision expectations you know how
many hours does he want to dedicate to
this
um how much money does he want to make
through this
do those correlate
um you know what what market
does he want to serve and is that market
there in your in your town and your city
that type of things i would just get
really really clear
on what he's doing what you're doing and
then i would baby step into it he sounds
like he's got a full plate already of
things and this may seem like a great
idea that when he gets into it he's
overwhelmed so let's just take it uh one
step at a time one client at a time one
you know and you'll you'll learn a lot
when you get into it about what he wants
to do more or less of what you want to
do more or less of but i would take it
slow start small grow slow and then you
can you can build on it more once you
learn a little bit i'll definitely um
lisa what do you do for a living she's
retired you're retired how old are you
retired nurse you're a [ __ ] nurse how
old are you
70. okay all right
and um
is he wanting to do this for you
no
okay he loves baseball i know that
but i mean is he wanting you to start is
he wanting you in this business to help
you are you struggling with money
no
okay no we're he's independent we are
independent
we've followed your
all of your things for years and okay
all right cool i just was making sure
that what the motivations were behind
all of this and what's going on so this
is just simply him wanting to help some
kids learn to pitch properly
and um he doesn't want to deal with the
administrative and business side of it
he just wants to do the pitching part
and you pick up the rest that makes
sense okay cool well i hope it works out
i'm with christy let's baby step into it
move slow into it incrementally so that
you guys can learn as you go and figure
out what your next step let's send her a
copy of business boutique that'd be
great reading for her anyway as she's
kind of having these conversations with
him absolutely that's perfect so uh
kelly i'll pick up linda and send you a
copy of business boutique elizabeth is
with us in canada hi elizabeth how are
you
hi i am thankful to god for his
blessings
amen me too what's up
um so my husband's 29 i'm 34 we're
expecting our first baby in july
we don't have any debt except for our
30-year mortgage
we have about 280 000 left on that
we've only owned it for a little over a
year we have thirty thousand dollars in
our emergency fund and
we have about forty three thousand
dollars just sitting in our savings that
we've saved up and kept there
and we're kind of a little bit divided
on what to do with that so my husband
looks at the numbers and he wants to put
it in investments for retirement
and i hate having the house debt and i
know that it's not a huge chunk in
relation to what we owe on the house but
i know that it would help pay down the
principal and i just i hate owing on the
house i don't like the debt and we don't
have any other debt so it's like that's
the one thing
um so but numbers why is he thinking it
won't get us ahead as fast as investing
will when you're looking 30 years down
the road so i guess with the question is
with that 43 000 chunk should we pay
down the principal on our mortgage or
invest now or split it somehow or just i
could just say screw it and get a brand
new toilet tacoma that would be like
well that's possibility
i mean if you're on board there you go
the uh
i mean if you have a purchase that you
need to make other than a screw it
purchase but i mean a legitimate project
that you want to make then that might be
a play but basically what we teach is
what we call the baby steps and it
sounds like you're aware of them baby
step one is and two is to be debt-free
everything but the house three is an
emergency fund you've done that beyond
that you have this 43 000 which we would
apply to
uh beginning your baby steps four five
and six simultaneously four is putting
15 percent of your household income into
retirement are you doing that
um well okay so yes and no so not 15 but
so the coolest thing is actually at my
husband's job
he makes about 90 000 a year and i'm
going to be a stay-at-home mom so i
wanted working but i'm not so our let's
just say we make about households 90
000. so at the end of each year his um
company gives him 12 of his annual
income above what he made and we use
that solely for investing so it's not we
haven't he just started there he's only
been there for a little over a year so
we've only received one
and that's just a lump sum bonus
yeah exactly and so i think it's
intended for investing and that's what
we use it for just goes right so we've
only been investing for a very short
time because
so what i would do is change your system
then you do not have a 90 000 income you
have 102 000 income
okay counting bonuses yeah okay give or
take 101 but somewhere right in there
and so i would be putting 15 000 a year
of your money
systematically monthly
into retirement savings
okay
and that that's a budgeting change for
you that's not that really doesn't
address the 43 000 but i would start
that immediately i would not do what
you're doing because you might not get
the bonus one year and you need to you
need to be in the habit of steadily
investing 15
of your income
and the um so
that that's the direction i would go now
the um
then the next step is do you have
children
one on the way in july then uh we might
use some of that 43 000 to set aside for
kids college maybe step five
and anything that's left beyond that i
would put it on the house
and uh and i am also doing math and part
of the math i'm doing is data that says
that the typical millionaire that we
studied in the largest study of
millionaires ever done in north america
shows
that the typical millionaire has
paid off home
and substantial money in retirement and
what i just laid out for you will get
you there
substantial money in retirement fifteen
percent fifteen thousand dollars a year
going into retirement and uh then beyond
that
uh uh
you know you're putting the
the uh money toward every dollar above
that towards getting the home paid off
and the typical person listening to the
show doing our steps pays off their home
in seven to eight years
the typical millionaire pays off their
home in about 10 years
but people following this stuff tend to
be a little bit more intentional a
little bit more intense
and move in that direction so somewhere
in that 7-10 range
house is paid for
but it won't be if you keep screwing
around and putting the 43 000 in
investments because quote unquote i did
some math
um which by the way was wrong
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
christopher is in dayton ohio hi
christopher welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so uh i'll try and make a long story
short i am uh divorced about three years
ago and in those three years i've been
to court
my wife's ex-wife is taking me to court
three times five times excuse me
so each time we go to court costs
anytime anywhere between ten thousand
and thirty thousand dollars uh i was on
baby step two just bumped down to baby
step one um so we're rebuilding our
thousand dollar safety or emergency fund
we are 96 thousand dollars in debt i am
remarried uh we have a household income
of 120 000. and
why does she keep taking you to court
um
i mean i don't want to speak illegal
i mean is this about kids or what's it
about
well in in her argument it's always
about the kids
but she's um
narcissists and depression so she lets
that guide her ways even though i keep
winning in court she keeps taking me
back just finding a different loophole
to do it and
so we're gearing up for her fifth round
now that she's taking me back for the
same reasons
okay
i think you need an attorney that gets
on the offensive
not just the defensive
because she's abusing the court system
it sounds like
she is my wife and i have talked about
we don't even know if it's legal to
start doing like uh harassment um
type of uh legal action towards you but
you you need an attorney you need an
attorney to investigate that you really
do because this is
i mean i'm just listening to what you're
describing and and you know people who
are continually doing that uh leave
themselves open to a lot type of
liability there and so
the abuse of the court system is a real
thing attorneys can be sanctioned for
that
and um certainly individuals can just
filing frivolous lawsuits is not allowed
you know
and so that's the you know i i keep
winning i keep winning and she keeps
looking for some angle so anyway that
that but anyway you so you've got 96 000
in debt is that what you said
yes sir how much of that is attorney's
fees
um that is current attorney fees is
about twenty five thousand dollars
okay and what's the rest of it
the rest of it is from going through the
divorce um i took on all the debt that
we had at the time and then um we uh
you know it was like a snowball effect
in the wrong direction for us we were
dropping everything to be able to pay
for attorneys so then we accumulate debt
because we have you know we could pay a
lawyer we could pay for food um i could
lose my kids or we could feed the kids
kind of thing so we ended up
making i wouldn't call them bad choices
they were just a noose around our neck
and we had accumulated credit card debt
um so how much credit card
uh credit card debt is sitting at um i
believe it's 22 000 right now because
that's 50 between those two things that
are associated with this what's the
other
50. and then there was a personal loan
to accumulate the uh the debt from when
the divorce first took place that's
currently sitting at 37 000 and then um
the the rest of it is
like kids and braces and stuff like that
kids and braces for fifteen thousand
dollars
uh no no um if that doesn't equal up to
exactly fifteen thousand i'm trying to
remember my dave ramsey uh that's our
website what all of it is credit card
and consolidation loan
yeah okay
oh and family debt because they helped
me pay for lawyers as well okay and you
make 120 household income now with your
new wife
yes sir okay good
all right um and then your question at
the end of this is what
so right now we're projected to pay off
if nothing else happened uh another 17
000 in debt by the end of the year and
we should be debt free by
mid august of 20 or excuse me mid um
2025 that's our goal
and i guess our question uh the wife and
i were sitting around talking and that
is what could we possibly do to better
protect ourselves so that
when
we do get slapped in the face with
another court um hearing
we're not scrambling for twenty thousand
dollars to to make it happen our our
goal we're trying to pick gazelles and
and uh knock out this debt as fast as
possible but every time we go to court
it really kicks us it beats us down yeah
yeah
hey i don't know uh it may be that you
treat this like it's a chronic situation
and say um
uh you know
if you had a an illness that cost you 20
000 a year that was chronic
you would have to put that into your
budget
and then above that work on getting out
of debt right
and so i i think you've got a chronic
legal problem for now
and you've got to continue so i put a
couple grand a month in the budget set
over in a separate savings account only
only for legal fees potentially if you
and it might be that if it happens again
we're going to use those legal fees to
be those attorneys fees to be offensive
okay
okay so you would say slow down
paying off the debt to build up a
account to build it well because you're
going to because you're you you have a
very high probability this is coming at
you again
yes sir
and so you know you've got to get ready
for it i mean this is a christmas is
coming in december a lawsuit is coming
from the ex-wife these are predictable
things
it is every time something good happens
in my life that seems to happen and i'm
not i'm not trying to be a black cloud
that's not my point my point is just
mathematically forecasting
we're just going to predict and if the
bad thing doesn't happen you've got the
money it didn't go anywhere but you
can't go buy a bass boat with it then
you got to use it for debt
absolutely so if for some reason she
decides to calm down without being
slapped into next week with an attorney
which may be what has to happen
um i mean sometimes you just have to
stand up and fight you know forward
rather than backward and uh i don't know
i mean i don't know the particulars are
your situation i'm not an attorney uh
but you know
i there there is a benefit to going
after
offensively some of these people that
misbehave using the court systems well
this is not working so you're five times
in th this is not working so we can't
you know i mean like i would try
something else after this fifth round or
whatever it is you know i i never
suggest i mean very very seldomly
suggest someone pick a fight right but
sometimes you have to finish one yeah uh
in order to you know in order for it to
be over yeah it's not going to be over
until you finish it yeah i mean you've
got to punch into punch and punch and
punch until it's over yeah and you just
stand there and and just you know and
the problem being in a fight is it it
doesn't just uh hurt the person that
you're hitting it hurts you yeah when
you're hitting you're you know if you're
physically we're in a fight your hands
will get damaged you know uh you know
boxers come out you know they're damaged
on but you know there's no no one gets
out of these things unscathed it's not
like there's one guy does all the
hitting and one guy doesn't right you
know everybody gets hit but the thing is
if you're going to go through all that
at least stick in it long enough to win
yeah where you don't have to fear this
every single year and just absolutely
defeat
the evil foe you know that's what you
and you have to take on that persona of
doing that and it's very difficult yeah
so it's emotional because you can hear
the emotional drain on him oh my gosh
like it's just never and he's talking
about he's going along with his life i
thought you were going to be the ex-wife
yeah but you're never
going away you know just go away i've
had people in my life like that just go
away just go go live your life over
there somewhere just go
away you know but they can't seem to do
it so they they don't get it no it's not
just a financial drain it's just that
emotional drain time the headache the
strain on your marriage your kids
it's it it's uh you know and you you go
from
uh
you know being angry to sad to back and
forth and i'm just i'm so sorry yeah
sorry you've been been through that yeah
and and and it's you know it's the
problem is it's stealing both the
emotion the spirit and the money from
your future with your current wife right
that's the problem you're taking your
eyes off of good things that could be
done instead you have to deal with this
crap yeah and this fight yeah and uh hey
been there myself know how it is not in
a divorce situation but in other
situations and you've just got to
you just have to uh the bad actors they
have to be punished
and you know you don't have any way
around it uh you know i i don't set out
to be sheriff andy but um but we'll
finish it you know if you're gonna pick
a fight and that's that's the re that's
where i'm coming from because i've been
in those situations and sadly in legal
battles where you have to become the
aggressor
rather than even though you didn't start
the fight right in order to stop it
that's how it works
all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five christy
wright ramsey personality is my co-host
james childs is our producer kelly
daniels our associate producer and phone
screener i am dave ramsey and we'll be
back
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsay call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice christie wright ramsey
personality is my co-host this hour this
day open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five you can
hear her on the christy wright show
where faith meets personal development
so you can have a bigger faith and a
better life you get the encouragement
you want with the tough love truth you
need to connect with god
take control of your life and enjoy your
life
new episodes every tuesday on youtube
and anywhere you listen to podcasts the
christy wright show open phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jeff's in daytona beach hi jeff how are
you
i'm doing well sir how are you doing
real happy to be on the phone with you
you too sir how can we help so i have a
question my wife and i are looking to
install a pool in our backyard and i uh
i know your your your thoughts on on
pools and and getting refinancing to use
the money for that but just a little bit
about my wife and i have lived very
financially responsible we have
no debt cars are paid off we have
college funds for the kids we maxed out
both roth iras we're also both pension
employees with the city here so we have
a pension to look forward to and we have
deferred comp
um
we bought our we currently owe 134 on
our home
our interest rate is 4.125
so we are wanting to install a pool in
our backyard we have two young kids we
are in what we consider our forever home
and we are wanting to refinance the
house and pull sixty thousand dollars
out of the house to install the pool you
wanna put a sixty thousand dollar house
in a hundred sixty thousand dollar pool
and a hundred thirty thousand dollar
house
so no we only owe 130 oh i'm sorry
what's the house what's the house worth
one third i'm sorry 330.
and the new rate we
yep the new rate we could get would be
2.375
i said that's an expensive pool
yeah oh yeah sixty thousand dollars is
an expensive pool that's uh that's
that's my wife's feeling
and that's uh that's uh
it is yeah it's her doing you're the one
calling jeff
i i know
it it it would be a very nice pool
and i know it's expensive but like i
said we are not planning on on going
anywhere at least until the kids are
through high school so that's about
another 13 years
you know for the youngest one
okay
um
well what you're
very clearly describing
over and over and over again and you've
said it six different ways is that you
know this is an irresponsible bad idea
yeah but you're trying you're but you're
trying to make me think it's okay
so that so that you're gonna think it's
okay
so that they will say
you're on to me
i mean it's just it's um
okay let's walk through it so number one
i'm not against fun number two you have
done a great job with your finances
congratulations number three you have a
clue where you are you know exactly
what's going on you're not a wandering
generality you're not out of control
you're you're very systematized you've
been very
uh
beautifully done you've told me your
numbers you're not you're not guessing
you know exactly where you are so you
have a lot of positive things going on
and and then you have this uh your
stomach is in your throat because you're
getting ready to pay too much for a pool
for a 330 000 house
it doesn't make sense to put that nice a
pool on a house that expense meaning you
would never recoup it
ever you're b you're over building the
neighborhood you have to be by
definition even if there's pools all up
and down your street they're not sixty
thousand dollar pools and three hundred
thousand dollar houses
people don't do that that is true okay
so number one you know you're spending
too much number two you're borrowing
money to buy a fun
toy yes and you know that that's not
unwise and um you called the guy that
was would tell you both of those things
right i mean what what do you want
how can i help you
could i could i run something by you you
think it's going to change my mind
i don't know
i try that technique jeff with my
husband all the time well let me just
give you one more all right let's try
let's let's try it let's try it
you're a good sport jeff let's try it
for fun here
so my wife and i we purchased the home
we've been in the home about six years
we purchased it for a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars
it has appraised quite a bit i i
understand
so the new if we were to refinance
um at a lower rate of 2.37 we would have
that the the mathematic equation you
give out we would with the closing cost
which is about 9 000 we would cover that
in about three years
we're going to be in the home for at
least i'd say at least 10 to 15 years
and with the refinance we're only
refinancing at 210 uh 210 thousand
dollars which is still substantially
less than what all the homes really
think it's gonna make you bankrupt
okay yeah i don't think you're gonna go
out of business because of this i don't
think you're going to
completely you know get a divorce
because of financial stress that's not
that's not what i'm saying
i'm saying a you're borrowing money to
buy a toy
true
even though you figured out some bass
awkward sophisticated way to make it
sound okay
but you're still borrowing money to buy
a toy and
you're over building your neighborhood
both okay so if you want to do if you
want to do one
if you want to do one of those over
build the neighborhood
okay
but don't but don't borrow the money to
do it
gotcha so i
and i so i i if i woke up in your shoes
i would do one of two things uh and is
do you have any money to put towards
this project
we would we have twenty thousand dollars
that we would put uh towards
but the way pools are built ever i mean
it's such a hot commodity here in the
state of florida right now that they're
putting an 80 000 pool in oh jeff you're
in more trouble now
oh it's a 60 000 pool oh okay so you're
borrowing you're willing to borrow 40.
yes sir i'm sorry okay no i'm
misunderstood i'm misunderstood okay so
you got 20.
so if you and what's your household
income
about 110 000 phenomenal okay
i would project that based on the fact
that you two actually have done so good
until we got to this conversation with
your finances
that the two of you could add another 20
000 to this 20 000 very quickly and pay
cash for a forty thousand dollar pool if
dave and sharon ramsey were in your
shoes
that's exactly what we would do
yes sir i'm gonna tell my wife we're
gonna have to eliminate sushi sunday and
that's that big that well no more it's
up to you it's not a lemonade it's trade
yeah we're trading it for a pool
you eat a lot of sushi apparently but i
was waiting for that but but your trade
you know you're going to eliminate some
lifestyle to get the pool that's what
dave and sharon ramsey would do we've
but we've got some nice toys in our life
and i remember the first time we bought
a toy we bought a little bitty dinky
butt house on the lake for a hundred
thousand dollars and we thought it was
the oh god we just bought a second house
we're like rich people or something we
have two houses
it was a hundred thousand hundred three
thousand dollars
and uh but we pay cash for it and we've
never regretted it we've never regretted
owning a lake house because we pay cash
for our toys and they don't come back to
bite you in the butt later
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business
check us out at
chministries.org
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
i'm proud of my state of tennessee
and uh one of the greatest things about
our state has been that we have had a
great run of incredible governors
at least the last two anyway and
governor bill haslam was a
governor here for two terms uh currently
governor bill lee is our governor in
tennessee and uh bill and i became
friends during that time christie's wife
as well and he was an incredible
incredible governor and uh
incredible
not politician but statesman is a better
word and has written a brand new book i
i went to donald miller's house the
other night with a bunch of folks in our
area here that were friends of both of
ours bills in mind and uh got to hear a
little bit of the reading from it and
the background on it it's called
faithful presence
the promise and the peril
of faith
in the public square bill and i are both
christians and it is messy when you once
you say you're a christian someone
disagrees with you immediately you're a
fake christian immediately uh someone's
got something to say about that but uh
you know how you can uh
act out your faith in
the public square
uh bill comes from the pilot oil family
his daddy is a started pilot oil and his
brother owns the cleveland browns and uh
if i got that right you got it right
okay and uh make sure i say the right
thing jimmy
big jim will get me jimmy for sure you
get a quick call but yeah i'll get i'll
get uh big jim would get on me i don't
want big jim after that but uh big
university of tennessee fans as well and
alumni like we are and uh uh generosity
in that direction so a little bit of
background there so bill you and i when
you uh were running for governor the
first time
uh with your background coming from a
family of means
we're sitting you and chrissy and i and
sharon were sitting on our back deck
remember kind of getting to know each
other right right a little bit
and i asked you a question i said why
would you take this job because it
doesn't pay
that much in comparison to other things
you could have done and have done in
your life
and you come from a family of means you
didn't it's not something you needed
financially and you didn't need the
power you didn't need any of that why
would you
why would you want that job it's kind of
what i said you remember that i do i
remember the conversation well and it
was an honest question because i just
couldn't envision it yeah well first of
all you talked about the success of
tennessee and ramsey and ramsey
solutions is part of that story i i got
to stand here where we are now when it
was a field um and to see what you have
done
to see what you've done with the place
as we say around tennessee is impressive
so first of all let me just
tip it was with your help as well no
cool story was a big help to us so why
do i run you know we all find different
ways to serve right you've been able to
change thousands and hundreds thousands
millions of people's lives by giving
them some insight into financial um a
better financial way to carry out their
lives
government serves a lot of different
people and it makes a difference who
governs matters and um for me it just
felt like a huge opportunity to serve
and i know it sounds kind of corny but
it felt like for me the way to to to
change more lives uh for the better than
than anything else i could do well and i
also remember you saying you felt like
god told you to i did it well and it was
a call a spiritual call is chrissy would
would always remind me during the
campaign campaigns aren't really much
fun and she'd say okay you you are
called to run the election will decide
if you're called to serve
[Laughter]
so there was always a whole lot of well
we'll see yes i will thanks for watching
but she was right and so we really did
feel that way and so if you do feel that
way then then you do it differently you
don't do it uh with you know your own
your own ends in mind bill haslam former
governor of the state of tennessee the
book is faithful presence the promise
and the peril of faith in the public
square so this your first book why write
a book about this subject and why now
you know uh it is my first book it might
might be my only you know some people
like you have enough to cover a lot of
books this might you know i only have
enough for one problem
but
here's why you know it's no secret the
country's at each other's throats uh and
everybody talks about the polarization
and we're not just that but we're mad
um and we're not just mad but we think
the other side has bad motives the
question is what are we going to do
about it well
jesus was pretty clear in in scripture
when something was wrong he always
started with us the religious types uh
and he said hey if the meat's gone bad
it's not the uh it's not the meat's
fault it's the salt's fault the salt's
not doing its job and so this is a call
to all of us who say that we want to
follow jesus and then others who don't
but want to know the role of faith in
the public square to say
what role could we have in being light
in the darkness and being sought to meet
and changing the tone of the
conversation
politics uh i you know anytime you get
up in the spotlight like i have been for
many years you get the haters and you
get the and you get the uh people who
believe you can do anything which both
are wrong right and um but the uh uh you
know you ought to run for office and i
immediately just about no no i have a
physical reaction
it it sounds so exhausting would be
balanced we know that that that's true
and there would be a lot of angry people
but yeah but uh it's messy it's
exhausting it's sometimes ineffective
why should we even care about politics
well
you know it says in scripture that god
causes the the sun to fall on the just
and the unjust the rain on the righteous
and the unrighteous so he cares about
the common good and this is a way that
that government impacts what we do and
how life works and again think about
your principles so tennessee's actually
lived that way we've lived as a fiscally
responsible state because of that we can
keep taxes low we can attract businesses
to come here it matters the decisions
you make and that affects again millions
of people uh because of that so
um
one of the reasons i wrote the book is i
don't want people to say oh a pox on
both your houses i'm tired of all the
argument uh i'm i'm not going to pay any
attention because
that's the wrong response to the current
situation
the the only way to fix it is engage i
stand back and throw grenades doesn't do
it it's never it's never worked and by
the way it's never changed anybody's
mind either yeah that's true
that's true
so
bill lee's been in office two years a
little bit more about two and a half
years so you know so you've been so the
last 10
plus years right we've been having these
conversations um
it feels like to me
that it's gotten a lot nastier
during that 10 years nationally yeah i
don't think it just feels like it has
and all the data would show you that
that it's we've gone from disagreeing to
think the other side has bad motives and
even that being contemptuous of the
other side yeah how do we get in this
mess
i think there's several things number
one we've always been a little i mean
we've always been
you know it's always been partisan you
know are the founders got literally
gotten duels with each other uh so so we
shouldn't kid ourselves and say oh this
is new but i think secondly the world's
different and so
with social media you can hide behind
the anonymity of the internet as you
know and people can say whatever they
want about you keyboard keyboard courage
the keyboard i love that i'm stealing
that uh
people can have keyboard courage people
can
uh
people can
in politics can say well i can just go
be a social media star i don't really
have to solve problems so it's like i'm
going to play a senator on tv i'm not
going to really be one in terms of
solving problems and i think the fact
that folks can choose their own news and
how they get it we we just tend to dig
further deeper into our own beliefs and
not take any time at all to listen to
is there a better way to do this yeah
the ability to sit down and calmly
listen to the other side is a lost art
it really is and somehow we think that
if we yell at the other side we're going
to change their mind and that's changed
nobody's mind everything doesn't you
know yeah i'm going to get mad and call
you names and on twitter and that's
going to make you feel better
yeah and i'm going to vote your way now
yeah exactly exactly
faithful presence is the book the
promise and the peril
of faith in the public square former
governor of the state of tennessee two
terms
bill haslam
what strengths and gifts
if people of faith come to the public
square should they be bringing well you
think about one of those that we should
bring is people always deciding am i
going to be a person of truth or a
person of love and we're supposed to be
both we're supposed to understand that
it's you know speak the truth with love
we're supposed to people think well you
either have to choose mercy or choose
justice and we understand it's both i
mean we actually have a god that lived
out
mercy and justice at the same time uh
and so we have a picture of that the
other advantage we have is
we know we're broken imperfect people
that's part of the definition of being
uh being a follower of jesus well if we
are that
then by definition we know we have the
capacity to be wrong too
that's not a bad place to start the
discussion yeah and that makes you a
listener i hope so
love your spirit love your humility
appreciate your friendship you too you
and sharon have
become great friends thanks governor
bill haslam former governor of the state
of tennessee check this book out guys
it's life-changing and it's really
needed in the marketplace right now
faithful presence the promise and the
peril of faith
in the public square
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in las vegas andrew and shanae are with
us it says on my screen you guys are
debt free congratulations
thank you how much did you pay off
seventy eight thousand five hundred and
sixty four dollars good for you awesome
and how long did this take you
364 days
okay there we go the one year minus a
day mark okay and your range of income
during that time
um our range of income started about
ninety seven thousand four hundred and
ten
and then we finished at um one hundred
and forty eight thousand nine or eight
hundred and forty wow what do you guys
do for a living
i'm a police officer and i'm the office
manager of a dental office how did you
get your income up so far in one year
um i worked over 901 hours of overtime
wow wow great place to go when you're
broke to work huh way to go andrew
man i bet you're happy this is over
yeah the wife's pretty happy too she has
help with kids now yeah absolutely she
was a single mom for a year
so uh
that's what that's what my wife said
yeah so uh
what kind of debt was your 79 000
uh it ranged from
we had a
personal loan for forty two thousand
dollars we had credit cards we had cars
and we had a thirty four hundred dollar
vacuum cleaner of course
yeah what well it does everything
or not but yeah so what was the 42 000
personal loan what was that
um so
we have two children and
i was a stay-at-home mom
for about almost three years and during
that time we thought it was going to be
a good idea to consolidate um a car
payment and credit cards into a
consolidation loan
and we were kind of you know at that
time we didn't know a whole lot about
paying off debt and stuff and we thought
at that time that was going to be our
best option and then when my daughter
was born um she had a lot of medical
problems and so we got behind on a
payment and it kind of just
downhill from there yeah i got you okay
yeah that thing you're trying to borrow
your way out of debt lots of folks have
tried that one you're not the only one
way to go i'm so proud of you guys what
started this uh this debt snowball this
lit your fuse because you guys went nuts
i mean you were going after it 901 hours
of overtime what started all this a year
ago
um so i had gone to a training with a
co-worker and during the training
finances had got brought up and he was
saying that he was getting ready to pay
cash for a million dollar home
and
i looked at him and i said how is that
possible like me and you have the same
job we're the same age like how how are
you doing this
and he grew up
uh in a ramsey household and so he
started telling me about it and i spent
a couple more days away from the family
at the training just looking this stuff
up
came home told the wife about it and we
were just right then and there we
started and we had kind of talked about
actually the options of
going bankrupt after that consolidation
loan like went to collections and stuff
because we were having all those medical
problems with my daughter
um and so
when he came home and was talking about
that it was like well we either do this
or we file bankrupt because we're not
really sure what to do and we were so
young that bankruptcy didn't obviously
sound too enticing so this was the only
other option we had and it sounded like
the best thing and we kind of just went
full force yeah you sure did
so how did you plug into us
when we were at the training he told me
your name so and then my mom had told me
about you when i was in high school and
something but i you don't listen to your
mom when you're a teenager yeah
and so
once i saw someone my own age living
that way
is when we started i started listening
to the podcast oh the podcast okay
every single day i've i have all of the
books the audiobooks that i've listened
to at least once a month
it's just we went crazy on it okay all
right cool and so the budgeting and the
whole process so what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is
sticking to a budget yeah
inconsistency i mean it gets hard and
you know you especially when you have
people um you know that you're friends
with or family that are kind of like oh
well you know and they live in like the
debt lifestyle and they're okay with
credit cards and they're okay well i
want the points you know i want this and
so you know you have those people that
kind of tell you what you're doing is
silly and stuff and um so my my opinion
is making sure that you're not listening
to that because there's a lot of people
that will try and tell you
um you know their other ways are better
and so just consistency and
really knowing what your goals are and
keeping keeping your goals in focus
because otherwise people really do try
to talk you out of it yeah there's a lot
of naysayers and it's just because they
don't have hope a lot of times
right and uh but who were your best
cheerleaders
um
oh man that stuff we had i think each
other honestly
we had some friends outside but me and
her one of us would start to feel a
little discouraged or something like
that and the other one would be like hey
knock that off like we got this let's do
this
and so we just worked together as a team
it would probably be the best thing but
we had some friends that stuck by yeah
what kept you motivated i know a year is
pretty fast for you guys to do this but
there had to be some some of those times
where you were getting discouraged would
you what did you guys tell each other
would you keep in mind to be able to
stick with it
i would say it was the
saying that dave has is live
like no one else so later you can live
and give like no one else so we figured
if we took a year away from being able
to do all the fun things and just really
put our heads to it
we would have a lifetime of being able
to do the fun thing that's awesome and
we have a four and a six year old and so
i think that was a lot of it too because
um i really want to be able to you know
send them to school and not have if
that's what they choose to do and not
have to have a lot of financial thing i
know i grew up
you know with a lot of hard like
financial situations and i don't want
that for my children um we've taught our
we've taught our kids um this kind of
thing and like even my six-year-old he
goes out and he gets a job cleaning up
dog poop for friends and they pay him
and we teach him how to like you know
spend save and give
so trying to show them
a good way of living with a lot of
motivation as well just trying to make
sure that they can see you know that you
have to work hard in order to
live freely later that's awesome so your
friend
andrew who paid cash at your age for a
million dollar house
you know that that's your son right
i really hope so yeah he's growing up in
a ramsey house that's right he's growing
up in a house where mom and dad are
living on less than they make mom and
dad don't borrow money mom and dad know
how to work their butts off and you're
teaching him how to work
you know i mean it would do a lot of
america good if at some point their kid
had picked up poop for money
it could change this country it really
could yeah
80 bucks a month going house to house
yeah that's awesome wow
that's awesome wow
this kid's an entrepreneur
uh no ken no pun intended but yeah
wow you guys this is incredible i'm so
so proud of you guys
very very well done absolutely
incredible uh so here's the deal we got
a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's uh the book about what happens
now the live like no one else part now
that you've done it
and the legacy that we're just talking
about with your kids and we've also got
a copy of the total money makeover for
you to take and give to someone because
now andrew you're going to be that
friend that runs into somebody and
starts their journey and uh that's how
this works so paying it forward so again
we're just so proud of you guys very
very well done all right it's andrew and
shanae
79 000 paid off in
364 days with 901 hours of overtime
making 97 to 148 they are free count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
three
two
one winners
amazing
you know it's not hard to work that hard
when you can see the light at the end of
the tunnel that's right and you can see
that you're getting there yes i love
that visual of how you said that's going
to be your sun like oh you forecast into
the future the ripple effect of this
decision with that next generation and
beyond that that's incredible change
your family tree baby
you can do it and i'm talking to you
yeah you
you thought you were just in the car
listing the radio now i'm talking to you
you need to change your family tree it's
in your power to do it
now do it
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
have you ever made a dumb decision
with zeros on the end because you didn't
do your research
yeah me too
sometimes we all make choices
dumb choices based on feelings or
opinions and if you do something like
that when you're buying a house
yeah
and this real estate market feelings are
not your friend
facts
are your friend because everybody's gone
bonkers out there check your fax
find out what you can actually afford
research what's really trending in home
prices talk to reputable real estate
agents in your area this is not amateur
hour where mark warehouses are getting
multiple offers do not let a monkey sell
your house
and a monkey can get a real estate
license
and they sell two houses and then you've
listed your highest most expensive
property asset with someone who doesn't
know what the flip they're doing get the
facts
know what you're getting into and get a
pro in your corner
go to ramseysolutions.com
agent you can plug in with one of our
elps our endorsed local providers that
we have vetted their high octane high
protein the top real estate agents in
the nation
ramsey solutions dot com
slash
agent
that's how this works
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
tina is in austin texas hi tina welcome
to the ramsay show
thank you for having me and listening i
listen to your podcast a lot well thank
you and um i just it's kind of like jeff
your earlier caller i feel like i'm
pretty frugal i'm really good with my
money um but i wanted to make sure i'm
on the right track and i feel really
stressed when i'm spending my money um
when or when i'm using my money for
myself when it's a gift or a donation no
problem anybody check but then when it
comes to me i get really nervous um
grocery store i don't want to binge on
the five dollar chocolate or whatever
right i just want to make sure i'm on
the right path of um
savings
uh so i'm on baby step number six um
paying off my mortgage i feel like i've
done a really good job with everything
else i skipped number five i don't have
any kids
um
and thanks to the podcast i got really
good so intense during um the pandemic
and i paid off my car this is pretty
dave ramsey i've heard about you for 10
years but i never really read the book
how can i help today
how sorry how can i help today
so i wanted to make sure that i was on
the right path for um
um when i paid off the mortgage i have
two different homes one's a rental under
an llc and then one's my home home and
then we always talk about paying that
off and as soon as possible so i wanted
to see which one should i pay off first
um
do i go get so intense and paying those
off and or do i just kind of loosen up a
little bit generally speaking what we do
is if they're similar in
payoff balance i'd pay off your home
first
but if you have a tiny little rental
mortgage and you want to just reach over
knock it out and then come back to the
home
uh that's okay too we're going gonna get
both of them eventually agreed
yes okay so how much is owed on each
um i owe 61
205 on the rental with five years left
and then 170
with 11 years left
and your income is what
uh taxable income is 73.
5 000. that's how much you're getting 72
000. taxable income 73. 73. 73 000 okay
all right the w2 is a 97 yeah okay so
you know the rental is substantially
smaller in balance yes
and if you wanted to push it up front
you can uh that would be a reason to
push it up front i always want to cheat
towards the residents
because of risk management and all that
means is in an absolute horrible worst
case scenario
if you were going to lose one to
foreclosure you'd want to lose the
rental
not your home
and so getting rid of the the place
where you lay your head down at night
having no mortgage releases you in the
spirit releases your spiritual you know
self a lot and then because of you know
the rental property and whatever we can
lose it or we can sell it and it's no
big deal but where you live gives you an
extra dose of peace when it is paid off
and so i tend to cheat towards that
so that's a reason to put it first but
the rental is very small so you can
knock it out pretty fast if you get
after it right
right so either one is okay in this case
but that's the way i look at it that's
the two things i look at is it and so if
you owed 150 on the rental and 170 on
your house i'd say go to your house
because of what i was describing earlier
but because your rental is so small if
you want to go over there first you can
do either one
you know again
you know we're only 230 thousand dollars
from being completely free
and that's pretty cool she's done a
great job yeah it's amazing it's always
good when the question is either option
is a good one
that's the answer yeah you know
you're in a good spot because you've
done really well yeah you've done real
smart uh and uh when both answers are
smart answers right yeah that's a that
that's a lot better than both answering
your dumb answers
yeah i've been there too
i've done both uh
joey's and how does hattiesburg hi joey
how are you
hi dave how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's
up well i'm 20 years old
i own two businesses one is a startup
but the other has been running for about
three years
um well for the one that's been running
i owe
176 thousand dollars
on the business
104 of that is owner finance loan
um 63 of it is through a bank
and then
9k is minor debt
well i know the general rule is never to
take out of an ira however i'm hoping
that you'll give me permission for an
exception
um i've got a cd for 64 000 and an
inherited ira for 700 i'm sorry 79 000
not bad
okay the inherited ira 79 and the cds
how much
64 000.
okay
all right
uh the owner finance loan um the one for
104k
said if i paid in full they would take
10 off
meaning i would save
10 400 on principal another 17 000 in
interest
and my idea is to use that cd put that
towards it and take the other 30 000
ira
yeah an inherited ira i would do that
when did you get the inherited ira
oh um three years ago
for my father okay i'm sorry
sorry for your loss there um
yeah and where did the cd come from same
thing
same thing
um it was life insurance okay and what
kind of business are you running at 20
years old that you won 170 000 in debt
for
um it's a vending machine business it
started out as two hundred and sixty
thousand um and i've been able to get it
down to there you're making money
um yes um to be fair during corona it
was barely paying for itself but
nevertheless paying for itself
how much do you make a month gross right
now
gross i mean it varies for month month
but
on average 8k
it's an idea yeah okay
so you're making like 30 grand a year
profit
as of right now yes um but i've had
that's because a lot of my business is
taken away i'm regaining it back
um now that coverage is coming to an end
in mississippi
absolutely
okay yeah i would have thought it would
be back
mississippi's open
it is but like the schools which is more
than half of my business oh
okay
all right all right that does explain it
okay and now you're out for the summer
exactly that's the reason my average is
so low yeah okay all right that's
helpful because i'm just afraid for you
these are these numbers scare the crap
out of me and here's number here's the
thing yes i would answer your question
yes i would do this i would take the cd
and enough out of the inherited and pay
the loan off i would also try to
negotiate down more than a 10 discount
because they probably need the cash
offer them 20 off
and just see what they say all they can
do say no all we'll do is 10 right so
just say i'm having to cash out my dad's
when he passed away inherited ira and
it's making me feel funny i'll do this
if you'll do 20
throw a little emotion in there see what
you can get them to do and uh here's the
thing i want you to walk away with don't
do this again
you won't have another one of these
shots to clean up this mess
next time you get ready to grow a
business or buy a business you pay cash
for it don't do this again
i'm scared for where you were you're
getting a one-way ticket out don't you
go back
that wasn't unclear was it no you you
covered it well this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to the
ramsay show dot com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host christy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life
and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five
five two two five kai is with us in
orlando is it k or kai
kai kai cool how can we help
so i'm i'll be on baby step two and i'm
working an extra job where i'm an
independent contractor and i think i can
pay off my debt in
way before next taxis and certainly by
the end of this year should i set aside
taxes still or should i should i wait
till later to get rid of those taxes
ready
yeah you're going to want to go ahead
and set those aside go ahead and plan
for them
do you know you have projections of what
you're what you're planning to do this
fall
uh yes so um so it's just an ex it's an
actual a couple hundred dollars a week
but uh it's it's my second it's soon to
be third job
um and my total uh debt is seven
thousand six hundred dollars
what do you make uh not counting this
job
uh that'd be about 32 000 yeah i'm just
i'm getting actually getting ready to
start the job next week okay oh cool
cool well
here's the here's the tech you're just
out of college
yes sir okay cool
here's what we're the proper way to do
this is to file quarterly
estimates
on the profits
of your business when you're an
independent subcontractor you're
technically running a business you have
a sole proprietorship okay
my guess is you don't have any expenses
associated with the business that are
deductible do you
i guess not other than maybe gas and
mileage
okay are you what are you driving like
uber each or something
uh yeah it's a grocery delivery okay all
right yeah you will have some deductions
there you'll want to keep track of all
that yeah you want to keep track you can
either write off uh the mileage by the
irs guideline or you can write off the
expenses associated with the car
one of the two
usually in your case the mileage is
going to be a better way
okay
so you have a deduction so let's say
that um your miles amount to 50
a week that you can write off and you
make 200 a week your profit would be 150
then you're following me
yes sir so what i would tell you to do
is this number one
um uh you can probably just jump online
and look and see what the irs is
allowing per mile and just keep up with
your mileage keep a log book of your
miles
okay
and you can do it electronically you can
do it in an old-fashioned log book if
you want to either one but you need to
keep up with it in case they question
you someday you need to have the records
that questioning you is called an audit
okay
so i don't think that'll happen but but
you don't want to get burned on this so
now
so you take the my the allowable
rate per mile times the mile you drive
and deduct that as an expense
and then once a quarter you're supposed
to file a quarterly estimate it's a
one-page thing it's very easy to do with
the irs
and it amounts to all of the money you
made at the grocery delivery in this
case minus the deduction you're taking
for all the miles during that quarter
that three month period of time
okay
the difference is called profit
what you brought in minus the miles is
your profit you following me
yes
times your tax rate and you're going to
send them a check for that amount once a
quarter on your taxes and so i don't
want you to wait until next year to pay
your taxes
because you're going to get penalized
possibly
for not paying them on time because
you're supposed to do it once a quarter
technically
and then when someone does that when
someone pays quarterly when they
actually comes around a tax time aren't
they just kind of reconciling the
difference at that point it's just so
much simpler on you as well you won't oh
if you do it properly you won't owe any
taxes on this portion of your income
next uh spring when you file your taxes
okay and i don't want that to sneak up
on you and hit you in the back of the
head later because we said oh don't
worry about taxes do that later
no yeah
that'll get you burnt right there man so
just go ahead and stay stay ahead of the
game the last snake you want to play
with is the irs snake
it bites
and dave for clarification for anybody
listening right now that is in a similar
situation don't you recommend percent if
you're not sure what your tax rate is
yeah twenty-five percent
set aside out of your income yeah so as
you're making it through that
three-month period of time you can kind
of be doing this calculation
i'm going to take the mileage off and 25
of the difference i'm going to set aside
in a savings account to be ready to pay
those quarterly estimates yep and that's
that way you'll have the money when the
quarterly estimate comes up because it's
you and i have with business boutique
and with entre leadership we have talked
to
thousands
of people who got themselves in serious
tax trouble they do not pay quarterly
taxes they don't even know they need to
pay them and they don't really realize
the benefit to themselves if they do of
just setting aside that as you get the
income as you get the revenue that you
set aside that twenty five
of your profit needs to be set aside on
a separate savings account
it's just for taxes don't touch it
it's tax money you're withholding on
yourself is all you're doing you're just
doing what they supposedly do for you
with withholding they seldom do it right
there you go open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five cole is
with us in utah hi cole welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave and christy uh thanks for
taking my call i'm very excited sure
what's going on
yeah so
i'm an interesting situation um
i started a i have a stable job as a
full-time fireman in vegas i live in
utah and i started a side gig to
help me to stay home more to supplement
some income and now that income has
grown and
the problem i'm having is i work 100
hours a week
about
and i have three babies at home and i
want to be home more so i'm trying to
figure out if
i should step away from my stable job
and
lose that sense of security and stick
with a commission-based job or what
that's going to look like how far away
from vegas do you live
it takes me about two and a half hours
to get to my fire station from my house
i don't understand that you do you do
this once
a day
four days a week no so
i work two days on and four days off so
i do a 48 hour yeah schedule so i drive
down once or twice a week and then i
come back
and then on your off days you have a
side gig that's kicking butt
yeah i'm a real estate agent so i
started doing that and it took my income
from just fire about 70 and now i'm
doing over 300.
okay
uh now
quit now driving
yesterday a long time ago
why do you have to think about it what
is the question
it's i know the market is hot now and
it's doing well as an agent but if it's
gonna
slow down and my income could drop
back down low and the security
well
if i step away from the fire job
on the fire department i lose that
that stability and that stable income
yeah you lose five hour commutes and
you're we see your three small children
dude you should have quit like 30 years
ago
wow
like by the end of the week you're not a
fireman anymore that's it
you have no life go get you a life
wow you are not afraid of hard work
though this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five summer's almost here but
that does not mean you can take a
vacation from your money goals
motivation to stay intense can go away i
understand but especially when you want
that beach trip or this kind of stuff
the old vacation uh waves in front of
you and you go
stop your whining
listen if you live like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else if you will vacate
like no one else
meaning not at all
later you can vacate like no one else
meaning anywhere you want to go baby and
there's some cool places in this world
you ought to be able to you ought to be
rich enough to go see
but you're not going to get there if you
keep spending money like you're in
congress
so it's time to straighten up a ramsay
plus membership
gives you our best digital money course
financial peace university all of our
digital money courses are there smart
money smart kids know yourself know your
money they're all in there legacy
journey
all the tools like the every dollar
premium the world's best budgeting app
all of this helps you keep moving
forward
it's about getting small wins that lead
to big results
your goals are worth working for all
year long
stay motivated
with a free trial of ramsey plus
text trial
233 789
that's trial
two three three
seven
eight
nine thanks for joining us america we
are glad you are here
christy it's worth going back to our
firemen for a minute yeah okay
seventy thousand dollars a year two and
a half hours each way commute
but he made three hundred thousand in
real estate she had a 370 000 income
three little kids at home he's working
100 hours a week
in in our minds it was and in most of
our listen most of you listening you
were going why this guy quit already why
in the world is he still doing this fire
thing
and what that says is this guy is
tremendously
driven by
a need for security
and he falsely believes
that the fire
fireman's job is more secure than the
real estate jobs yeah and that's a
falsehood which is interesting too
because i've noticed a pattern where
we've had some similar calls not the
same question where it's well when is it
okay to do this and it's like it was
okay ten years ago but it's that we we
hold on there's this fear that keeps us
trapped in some idea that that we we're
not there we don't have enough the what
if i lose my job i've heard you ask
people well how stable is your job
they're like
oh i don't know something could happen
but it's a very stable job they've been
there for 20 years and the industry's
secure and
and so it's just interesting how fear i
feel like is this shadow that haunts us
and because we never really pin it down
and define us it can always torment it's
like what if what if what if but the
scenarios are not even remotely probable
they're not realistic
well and when it comes to
your income
it can be the tapes that were played in
your house when you were growing up
in the sense of always get a good job
and the definition of a good job is that
it that it's always going to pay yeah
it's a steady work it's steady it's in
its income you can count on
and versus being self-employed
or straight commission yeah which is an
unstable job right
but it's not necessarily an unstable
income what's interesting though is i'm
curious have you seen a correlation
between
uh preference in terms of like salary
commission you know however it's
structured by personality style
because like no i think i think it's
just a uh it would be back to rachel's
book know yourself know your money it's
abundance versus scarcity or
it's um
you know we all have one of those
uh but the the scarcity mentality i
would just go with that as an example
and that could be any personality style
but it usually would go back to your uh
the way you were brought up the
household you grew up in
and um
[Music]
and you will either react way to the
opposite of the way you grew up or
you'll try to do the same thing again
one of the two and but very seldom just
in the middle yeah until you look up and
you go wait a minute the way i was
brought up is what's influencing this
not the facts
feelings are not facts yeah and and so
uh here's an example okay if you've made
three hundred thousand dollars in a
white hot real estate market if the real
estate market cools off you've done
enough transactions you know how to do a
transaction
you ought to you ought to it's logical
the facts would indicate
that the chances of you making
uh
let you know one-third
of what you used to make or greater
is very high based on your track record
right
and how long you've been doing this
you've been doing it longer you have
word of mouth you have referrals there's
there's not enough transactions that if
you if you didn't make 300 but the
market cooled off and you only made 100
but you used to make 70 as a fireman you
still came out ahead
so that it ought to give you all kinds
of emotional breathing room to be able
to quit the quote-unquote steady job but
here's the problem people think that
where they work is how what makes it
steady and it's not
your
talent and ability to land a job doing
something is what makes is the only
thing that gives you stability and so if
you're a high quality salesperson you
can always land a job in doing sales
always in any marketplace at any time
now you may have to change you might you
might be doing medical devices and later
you might be doing cars or later you'd
be doing cars and later you're doing
medical devices or pharmaceuticals i
don't care but a sales person that knows
how to sell and has worked on straight
commission and knows how to has a high
relational iq regardless of the
personality type has a proven track
record
you're only as secure as your own
ability
the fact that the that it's the
government that pays the firemen makes
you secure no
what makes you secure is
you have the ability to leave the cave
kill something and drag it home and it's
proven
that's where your security comes from
and and so
but and you have to use those as dr john
dolone would say we use facts are our
friends and the way we overcome trauma
is uh we calm down and we deal with
facts
not the emotions of the situation and i
think that releases people to go live
their dreams then yeah it's interesting
too because it's when you break it down
like that it helps people see oh i had
some beliefs about stable versus
unstable
job that had nothing to do with what the
company is or where the money comes from
we've seen something similar when it
comes to non-profit or for-profit status
and building a business so i work with a
lot of business owners and they say well
i want to i want to structure my
business as nonprofit because i want it
to somehow be holy and do work that
matters because as if the irs
designation is somehow the holiness
factor and so we'll have i will attach
ideas to statuses especially in relation
to government that are not actually
accurate at all but i have a friend that
owns a small business that has grown
year over year over year over year for
20 years he's not made his personal
income out of that business that he paid
taxes on
for the last 20 years has not been under
a million dollars a year that's
incredible yeah that's incredible yeah
but
and so is his
income
stable
yes for 20 years yes yeah you know but
it's all but but cove had affected it
yeah covett could have dr you know could
have dried up his market could have done
but is his income stable yes yeah it's
an income statement it's got 20 years
right of being able to do this it wasn't
one time right it wasn't just not this
young man here was he it was one time
and it isn't just during why dot covid
and so forth but he's out there still
getting stuff done he's there's a lot of
real estate agents who haven't even been
able to figure out how to sell a house
in this mess which means you really do
need to get out of the business but um i
mean because god almighty anything can
sell a house right now but the uh but
but you know maybe you won't make 300
but you've got 300 000
of income that many transactions under
your belt that says you know how to look
at people and get them to the closing
table yeah on the par on the purchase of
their next home their dream yeah you
know i participate with them in that in
a way that causes them to do the
transaction yeah
and and so that is stable yeah
and to your point where you're paid or
who's paying you doesn't make it stable
right and to your point your second year
if the market cools off and you take a
small dip your dip is still way ahead of
where you were in the firemen job so you
have to look at it in relation to what
you're comparing it to as if somehow 70
000 is stable when you're talking about
even a dip would still be way above that
which makes
his call for
most people listening a no-brainer yeah
but for something inside of him that was
holding on to this false notion of where
stability comes from
stability comes from your ability
say it again stability comes from
your ability
it doesn't come from anywhere else and
god's blessings but it doesn't come from
anywhere else but those two things
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five
two two five
on the la on the debt-free stage in the
lobby of ramsey solutions chris and
amanda are with us hey guys how are you
doing very well thank you welcome
welcome good to have you where do you
guys live
ozarks awesome beautiful area huh yeah
it is cool and all the way down here to
do a debt-free scream how much did you
pay off
278 767
wow how long did this take four years
one month and 19 days i love it and your
range of income during that time about
130 135 140 somewhere in there what do
you guys do for a living um we're in
higher education both of us
what are your professors uh-huh yeah
cool good for you yeah thank you i teach
chemistry for a junior college
um i'm a chair over a masters of science
and nursing program and i teach in that
program as well wonderful awesome very
cool
so uh i was gonna say four years and 279
000 might be
a mortgage but that might be student
loans a lot of it we had to pay for a
lot of brains
between the two of us we have been
purchasing brains yes we have five
degrees between the two of us it's wow
too much we over degreed ourselves
it was wow
bad decisions all around okay
your professors
we are using it yeah and you know what
honestly we're lifelong learners we love
to learn you know so it was really good
we love to teach we love our students
both of us we're really passionate about
it we just um
you know regrets about getting there the
way that we got there but um that's okay
because we were able to
get out of it and now we're kind of on
the other hand
it definitely is yeah so
how four years ago the time that you
finished the last degree then
uh yeah we started the program about um
a half a year before i completely
finished my phd okay okay so you're
doing dissertation and stuff because
you're doing it i was yeah wow yeah
what's your phd in uh educational
technology i'm online teaching is sort
of my specialty so wow
you got a little bit of a future
wow you talk about stepping into them
yeah and a dissertat and a dissertation
in the middle of a pandemic huh
well yeah just leading up to it no no no
no you started four years ago i'm sorry
i'm sorry i am in healthcare so you know
yeah wow
yeah amazing yeah very cool
very cool good for you guys so uh how
long have so you were you were working
on your phd how long y'all been married
almost 22 years now oh okay yeah so
somewhere along the line of this journey
of gathering degrees and education and
lifelong learning and
all of this
five years ago or so something happened
into the 22 marriage what happened so
2017
uh well late 2016 we just got to the
point or at least i felt like
you know all the money that was going
out you know versus all what's coming in
it just ended up being nothing left over
it just felt like a financial abyss at
the end of it so that's how i felt but
what about you yeah i think that
um we are both people of integrity and
we knew that
we were signing for something that we
were eventually going to have to pay and
i think as i got closer and closer to
the end of my educational
journey i was watching it come my
friends some of them were going bankrupt
some of them were
starting to get their bills in the mail
because you know they don't start
billing you for those student loans
until you're out
and so i was seeing the size of their
bills and their bills were like mortgage
payments or more and i mean it was
giving me a visceral reaction yeah
and i think we just both of us just went
oh you know the
the piper's coming like we're gonna have
to figure out a plan to get this taken
care of and we're both people of logic
and it was so nice to have
this to sort of latch onto to say okay
here's a plan here's a
proven method that we can use to to sort
of work our way through step by step
connected to us
um i watch a lot of youtube videos and i
just was following somebody who
used the ramsay plan cool and um we got
the book and we both read it and we
decided we were going to get on board
and it was very
let's say
i think it was intimidating to go up
against that large number after we
actually let the monster out of the
closet because it really felt that way
but
and i think um you know after we started
budgeting and actually doing it and
following it then we start gaining
confidence
um and you know since it was such a
four-year long journey you know probably
in the middle of it felt you know felt
stagnant but we were making progress so
we kept going
you know but the last year went a lot
faster of course
with covet everybody was at home so
there was no way you're going to spend
money anyway so you know it was we
leveraged the advantage of you know we
were paying off
all the student loans at the end because
they were the big biggest part yeah and
so you know we just kept going it's gone
so we don't have to worry about it
so i'm i'm interested with
um the amount of education and you said
we're people of logic um when you uh
because so much of what we do we
approach this through almost emotion
yeah or behavior modification anyway but
when you when you lay down like the baby
steps in front of you or the debt
snowball in front of you it was just
instantaneous you just saw it said okay
let's do it
i mean i i think that
i watched other people sort of on
youtube who
had done it and and were successful and
i said well it worked for them we can
make this work for us too but we've
always sort of plowed
face-first into life and just done
things
with a lot of confidence that we we are
a team and we're going to be able to
conquer this thing so i think this was
no different i think we just sort of
came into it very confidently like it
may take us and my first calculation we
did the excel spreadsheet at the very
beginning was that it was going to be
seven years
and
you know we got it done in four a little
a little over four
we just picked up all the overtime and
overload that we could pick up but what
do you attribute the difference
the difference between four and seven
well i think it just
working together at the same goal versus
just kind of doing whatever
the individual wanted to yeah you were
able to sacrifice deeper than you
thought when you did this yeah we did we
definitely did it's on the shirt i mean
we're a team
and it's so different working together
it's one of those things like my
students there's nothing a student hates
worse than a group project
really but it's such a valuable skill to
be able to work with another person
and to
enhance each other's strengths and also
work against each other's weaknesses but
also to work towards a common goal you
almost
it's it's more than one plus one is two
it's you one plus one is three you know
it's more than that so team cole does
have their own little university emblem
there
it's pretty cool they have uniforms
they probably have a soccer team yeah
we're not sports people
well done you guys i'm so proud of you
so okay when people ask now you paid off
279 000 in four years in one month how
did you do that what's the secret to
getting out of debt i think being a team
and sticking to the budget even if you
don't have the confidence yet i think
you gain that over time and you gotta
both show up to the meeting you can't
get to scape out on it you can't get to
skip a month
yeah and i think working the plan um you
know you find that plan that works and
then you commit yourself to it you've i
mean
a million people have said this on the
show but you have to submit yourself to
the actual plan and not try to do ish
um nobody is the exception nobody's the
exception to the role everybody thinks
they're the exception but you know the
rules are there for a reason and it
works so yeah they're they're there
because they work now with other reason
there's nothing here to punish you it's
still it's a bless you
yeah so proud of y'all thank you very
very well thank you very much who were
your biggest cheerleaders outside the
two of you uh well obviously the two of
us but we had some family and then i
think my daughter was amazing
smart fester who has followed us through
this whole thing so now we're actually
using him yeah so he helped us out thank
you rick and then we um also have an elp
with a realtor so we're oh my god yeah
it was one of the coolest things it was
at the end of all of this we were able
to
um
move into our dream home
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you that's the next chapter in your
story legacy is all about the what this
is all about and a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away and
pay it forward to somebody you guys are
impressive very well done rock stars
heroes well done
chris and amanda from ozark missouri 279
000 paid off at four years in a month
making 135 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
wow that is so awesome what a great
story
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day lamentations 3
22 23 because of the lord's great love
we are not consumed
for his compassions never fail they are
new every morning
great
is your faithfulness
henry ford said the only real mistake is
the one from which we learn nothing
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air nathan is
with us in minnesota hi nathan welcome
to the ramsey show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
so i'm i'm currently an accountant for a
large company i've been there about 14
years
my gross income is about 180 000 per
year
i'm married i have three small children
my wife and i don't have any debt we
have about three hundred thousand
dollars in
uh iras and and um 401ks through my
employer to my wife's employer
i have about forty five thousand dollars
in savings
uh and
right now i have the opportunity to
buy into a well-established tax practice
with one other person
i currently have a cpa
my my half investment in the business
would be about a ninety thousand dollar
uh share
and the gross proceeds of the of the tax
practice is about two hundred thousand
annually so
my my cut of that my half would be about
a hundred thousand
and we would operate it as you know s
corpse each uh myself and the other
individual
and so i'm just trying to assess
you know what that kind of pay cut would
would mean to my current life situation
where you have 45 000 where are you
getting the other 45 to put the 90 into
it
um actually so i've i've met with the
current tax practice owner and the other
person who who's looking at buying it
and it would be over
basically over a two year time frame so
not not next tax season but the
following so
by the time i would be
transitioning into this tax practice i
would have the 90 000 saved up in cash
to just pay good pay for the half of the
business okay and uh i assume you
project that you can grow the business
then
correct okay
and um
the there's going to be one sub s corp
and each of you are going to own 50
that's correct okay
all right well i'm sorry no each of us
would would have an s corp
on our on our own and basically the
so whatever tax returns we
or whichever clients and tax returns we
fill or we fill out we would uh take
those proceeds oh actually okay so you
would have to settle you would have a
book of business and he would have a
book of business
but you're basically sharing office
space under the umbrella of the larger
okay okay all right that works
and that makes it easy to manage and
um you know we know who owns what then
that you actually own those clients
that's correct okay that's good that's a
clean way to do it i i would suggest you
get uh just as a sidebar uh some legal
advice on putting together
uh
it's not really partnership agreement
but it might actually be how these two
sub-s's are going to interact
share expenses and you always cover all
the negative things we call them the ds
divorce drug use default disability
death what happens in the event of these
things and so you address those things
up front but that's a fairly normal
process in the type of business that
you're going into normally i steer away
from partnerships but this is a unique
this is like a medical practice in a
sense they're a law practice in a sense
that it's done differently so i'm fine
with it right
so you make 180 your wife makes what
uh right now she's at about 35
but she she'll be starting a new job
in the fall where she'll be around 60 60
to 65.
okay so you would take an 80 000 pay cut
year one but she would have picked up 35
000 of that
that's
correct okay and and her concern is
around you know right now we have very
cheap health care through my employer
that covers our whole family
and
she she would work for a school
and her
her health care package to through her
employer is
is not nearly as good as mine so it's
really just the the uncertainty around
yeah
it's not that's not that's
whoop-dee-doop-dee that's not a big deal
okay yeah you just need to run your
numbers and create a budget based on
this new income i think when you can see
it on paper and see how you can live on
this new income including whatever
health care increase in health care
costs then you're going oh yeah we can
do it it just feels scary because you
can't see it you haven't put it on paper
yet but you may have 220 now you'll be
at 160
then
or 165 then
and uh on your way back to 220. surely
to god you can make it on 160 you don't
have any debt
right it's that perceived fear we were
just talking about yeah so chrissy's
right you need to the two of you need to
write it down and actually look at it
when you look at actually what the
health care difference is it's a penance
compared to your income yeah
it's not going to be 10 of your income
it's not going to be five percent of
your income it's going to be two percent
of your income that's affected by this
it's that perceived security because
it's coming from somewhere else and now
you're going to be doing it on your own
and you just need to see how you can do
it and that will help relief from some
of that yeah your big hit is going from
180 to 100. that's the big hit it's not
the healthcare
right that is and i calculated the
i calculated the hours out and it's only
about
six months of equivalent work versus
what i do today in 12 months you know
it's a little bit of
of higher volume obviously in the tax
season which we'd have to manage through
with our little kids and their schedules
and things but but then i'd have you
know late april through december
of lowell now i haven't worked been
responsible in your current situation
for building the book of business where
you are or were you just executing
widgets
yeah i i manage um
a large portion of the of one side of
the business so all the budgeting and
the financial oversight of it so well
the acquisition of new clients
um no we're we're a large uh yeah
that's what i'm talking about i thought
so okay so that's a skill you don't have
proven
that you'll need to get in order to
raise your 100 000 income to 200
000. that's a true point yes yeah so we
some you know you're gonna learn about
practice management marketing
client acquisition development of new
new books of business
all all of those kinds of things to grow
grow grow grow grow uh rather than just
simply
churning out tax returns
uh and so that that can be
that could be the challenge of this
situation but there's tremendous upside
and i love the idea of what you're doing
yeah yeah and you could use those slower
seasons to work on those the skills and
clinic client acquisition yeah it's uh
but this is a really good move i
definitely would do this haley is with
us in
dallas haley i'm short on time go
straight to your question
yes uh hi i'm uh i lost my job in
september as a director
uh making a hundred and thirty thousand
uh
i'm talking to a recruiter today
uh for a senior director position
fortune 100 company i'm trying to
negotiate a higher salary but i'm not
sure how much i should negotiate for
have you done your research on what the
company pays what the position pays any
of that kind of digging yeah i've looked
online and i'm not really sure what to
trust as far as the numbers go but i uh
i indicated i wanted a 148 000.
okay so you've already put a number out
there
i did
she gave me an offer today for 125 000.
which
was really low and i told her it was
that i really wasn't
that i was interested in a higher salary
than that
i just
don't know since i you know lost my job
and i haven't really gotten a lot of
callbacks um i just didn't want to
settle for something low but i don't
know what's the right
salary well if you're worth 150 in the
market i would wait unless you're unless
you're having trouble paying the bills
have you got some backlog have you got
some money
um yeah i'm doing good okay as many days
yeah then you know don't take it lower
job just out of lack of confidence then
but the question is you need to do a
detailed comp study
and uh you know
more than one site on the internet can
help you do that there's plenty of
places we do comp studies around here
all the time on what a senior director
in that region where that company is is
being paid and present that back to the
headhunter and say look this is what the
comp study says
it says they're 25 000 low
that puts us hour today ramsey showing
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
you